you know I didn't go to my prom and now
I've seen Carrie and now I'm glad I
didn't Carrie
so Carrie is the new on screen
adaptation of the Stephen King book
Carrie Carrie is about Carrie played by
Chloe grace Moretz she's the social
outcast girl she sits in the back of
class you know she's very timid everyone
picks on her calls her a freak you a
pretty classic bully case only thing is
Carrie one day discovers she has
telekinesis so you know she's gonna make
some people at least a couple people pay
for being dicks and in Carrie you have
Carrie's mom who is the real freak let's
be honest Carrie is actually a pretty
normal girl given the circumstances her
mom out of her mind
carrying her mom are like the Flanders
family from hell if they were still
really really religious now I'm going
into Carrie I wanted one simple thing I
wanted to see a girl get bullied get
ridiculed get telekinesis and then get
vengeance you saw scream which means you
know they used corn syrup I got what I
wanted and I enjoyed Carrie it's a short
movie it's a direct to the point kind of
movie I wanted to see more of Carrie
developing or telekinesis you know like
the movie Chronicle or something but in
the end I did like the world I like the
fact that not all of the students were
there were a couple of nice
people not just you know that one weird
friend who's also weird so she's friends
with Carrie and they're both social
outcasts like among the popular people
there are a couple of people who are
like yeah just don't need to be addicted
Carrie it just makes it a little more
realistic and I like the character of
Carrie Carrie's like Harry Potter if
Harry Potter one day just had enough and
he was like stop stop picking on me do
you know what America Deborah I'm
surprised he never did that honestly
spoiler alert he doesn't do that I just
connected a bit with the character of
Carrie I don't know maybe because I was
the weird kid in high school sitting in
the back of class kinda by himself at
the nerd table a couple of the douchebag
students in this movie who give Carrie
are really extreme like to an
unbelievable kind of degree like dude
you're almost you're homicidal but the
fact is it is based on the Stephen King
novel I haven't read the novel Carrie
but I have read some Stephen King books
and I know he does have characters like
that like Allah's book so in that I
gotta assume they're probably being
loyal to source material that or they're
not being loyal to source material at
all carriages like that are not even in
the carey book and i'm just i'm full of
right now Chloe grace Moretz was
awesome in this move
Julianne Moore was awesome in this movie
the movie Carrie has a very simple goal
you see a girl get ridiculed she gets
telekinesis and then she gets her day I
almost feel like I'm spoiling that but I
don't think I am because the trailers
show it it's almost a pop culture thing
at this point like socially everyone
knows what happens in the movie Carrie
and I went into this movie knowing what
happens at the end of Carrie I was
looking forward to it oh yeah this is
gonna be awesome part of the experience
is knowing what happens in the end I
will say the movie Carrie is a good time
no alcohol required I had a good time
watching it if I'm hanging out at a
friend's house and were flipping through
the TV and carries on about oh no check
this out this ain't bad right so Stephen
King books what's your favorite Stephen
King book dude has a lot of them out
there he's retired like 72 times in the
past decade keeps coming back keeps
making him so whatever it is comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more